on a warm August morning in Harare far I
a 24 year old mother of two walks
towards a park bench she looks miserable
and dejected now on the park bench sits
an 82 year old woman better known to the
community as grandmother jack for I
hands grandmother Jack an envelope from
the clinic nurse grandmother Jack
invites for I to sit down as she opens
the envelope and reads the silence for
three minutes or so as she reads and
after a long pause grandmother Jack
takes a deep breath looks at four eye
and says I'm here for you would you like
to share your story with me far I begins
her eyes swelling with tears
she says grandmother Jack I'm HIV
positive
I've been living with HIV for the past
four years my husband left me a year ago
I have two kids under the age of five I
am unemployed I can hardly take care of
my children tears now flowing down her
face and in response grandmother Jack
moves closer puts her hand on far I and
faith for I it's okay to cry you've been
through a lot
would you like to share more with me and
far I continues in the last three weeks
I have had recurrent thoughts of killing
myself taking my two children with me I
can't take it anymore the clinic nurse
sent me
to see you there's an exchange between
the two which lasts about 30 minutes and
finally grandmother Jack says for I it
seems to me that you have all the
symptoms of CO fungus ISA the word Co
fungus ISA opens up a floodgate of tears
so Co fungus ISA is the local equivalent
of depression in my country
it literally means thinking too much the
World Health Organization estimates that
more than 300 million people globally
today suffer from depression or what in
my country we call Co fungus ISA and the
World Health Organization also tells us
that every 40 seconds someone somewhere
in the world commits suicide because
they aren't happy largely due to
depression occur from disease and most
of these deaths are caring in low and
middle income countries in fact the
World Health Organization goes as far as
to say when you look at the age group
between 15 to 29 a leading cause of
death now is actually suicide but they
are wider events that leads to
depression and in some cases suicide
such as abuse conflict violence
isolation loneliness the list is endless
but one thing that we do know is that
depression can be treated and suicides
averted but the problem is we just don't
have enough psychiatrists or
psychologists in the worlds to do to do
the job in most low and middle-income
countries for instance the ratio of
psychiatrists to the population is
something like 1 for every 1 and a half
million people which literally means
that 90% of the people needing mental
health services will not get it in my
country
there are 12 psychiatrists and I'm one
of them for a population of
approximately 14 million now let me just
put that into context one evening while
I was at home I get a call from the ER
or the emergency rooms from a city which
is some 200 kilometers away from where I
live and the ER doctor saves one of your
patients someone you treated four months
ago has just taken an overdose and they
are in the ER department hemodynamically
they seem to be okay but they will need
newer psychiatric evaluation
now I obviously can't get into my car in
the middle of the night and drive 200
kilometers so as best as we could over
the phone with the ER doctor we come up
with an assessment you know we ensure
that suicide low observations are in
place we ensure that we start reviewing
the antidepressants that this patient
has been taking and we finally conclude
that as soon as Erica I was her name
26 year old as soon as Erica is ready to
be released from the ER she should come
directly to me with her mother
and I will evaluate and establish what
can be done and we assume that that will
take about a week the week passes three
weeks pass no Erica and one day I get a
call from Erica's mother and she says
Erica committed suicide three days ago
she hanged herself from the mango tree
in the family garden now almost like a
knee-jerk reaction I couldn't but help
asking but why didn't you come to her RA
where I live we had agreed that as soon
as you're released from the ER you will
come to me her response was brief we
didn't have the $15.00 bus fare to come
to her RA now suicide is not an unusual
event
in the world of mental health but there
was something about Erika's death that
struck me at the core of my very being
that statement from Erica's mother we
didn't have $15 bus fare to come to you
made me realize that it just wasn't
going to work me expecting people to
come to me and I got into this state of
soul-searching trying to really discover
my role as a psychiatrist in Africa and
after considerable consultation and
soul-searching talking to colleagues
friends and family it suddenly dawned on
me that actually one of the most
reliable resource we have in Africa our
grandmothers yes grandmothers and I
thought grandmothers are in every
community there are hundreds of them and
and and they don't leave their
communities in search of in search of
greener pastures see the only time they
leave is when they go to a greener
pasture called heaven so I thought how
about training grandmothers in
evidence-based talk therapy which they
can deliver on a bench empower them with
the skills to listen to show empathy all
of that rooted in cognitive behavioral
therapy empower them with the skills to
provide behavior activation activity
scheduling and support them using
digital technology you know mobile phone
technology pretty much everyone in
Africa has a mobile phone today so in
2006 I started my first group of
grandmothers
today there are hundreds of
grandmother's who are working in more
than 70 communities and in the last year
alone more than 30,000 people received
treatment on the friendship bench from a
grandmother in a community in the in Bob
way and recently we published this work
that is done by these grandmothers in
the Journal of the American Medical
Association and and our result our
results show that six months after
receiving treatment from a grandmother
people were still symptom free no
depression suicidal ideation completely
reduced in fact our results with this
was a clinical trial in fact this
clinical trial showed that grandmothers
were more effective at treating
depression than doctors and they are
and so we're now working towards
expanding this program there are more
than 600 million people currently aged
above 65 in the world and by the year
2050 there will be 1.5 billion people
aged 65 and above imagine if we could
create a global network of grandmothers
in every major city in the world you
know ah who are trained in
evidence-based talk therapy supported
through digital platforms networked and
they will make a difference in
communities they will reduce the
treatment gap for mental neurological
and substance use disorders finally this
is a file photograph of grandmother Jack
so far I had six sessions on the bench
with grandmother Jack today far I is
employed she has a two children at
school and as her grandmother Jack one
morning in February we expected her to
see her two hundred and fifty seventh
client on the bench she didn't teach up
she had gone to a greener pasture called
heaven but I believe I believe that
grandmother Jack from up there she's
cheering on all the other grandmothers
the increasing number of grandmothers
who are making a difference in the lives
of thousands of people and I'm sure
she's in all when she realizes that
something that she helped to pioneer is
now spreading to other countries like
Malawi the island of Zanzibar and coming
closer to home here in the United States
in the city of New York may her soul
rest in peace
[Applause]